ما قصه ارتباط غافي باميره اسبانيا بعد
مونديال قطر قلاده كوندي في مباراه فرنسا
و بولندا تثير الجدل على السوشيال ميديا
وتيتي يعتذروا قبل مباراه البرازيل وكوريا
الجنوبيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها
على العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
المنتخب الفرنسي والجدل الذي اثره عبر
السوشيال ميديا خلال مباراه منتخب بلاده
امام بولندا في مواجهه قطر بدا المباراه
وهو يرتدي قلاده حول عمقه وهو امر فجر
موجه غضب عارمه بين الجماهير البولنديه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
على لوائح الفيفا التي تمنع ابتداء اي شيء
قد يتسبب في اصابه المنافسين فقط التحكيم
انتبه للامر في الدقيقه الثانيه والاربعين
من المباراه من اللاعب الفرنسي
تصدرت ليونر ابنه ملك اسبانيا اخبار
السوشال ميديا ايضا خلال اليومين الماضيين
بعد ما اكد التقارير الصحفيه ارتباطها
بكافي احد لاعبي ماتادور القصه بدات بعد
فوز الفريق على كوستاريكا وتوجه ملك
اسبانيا المتواجد حاليا في قطر الى غرفه
تغيير الملابس الخاصه باللاعبين لتهنئه
الفريق على الانتصار لوحظ وقتها ان الملك
لديه قميص موقع من جاري وبحجم اصغر بكثير
من القميص المعتاد الامر الذي فتح باب
التكهنات بان القميص لابنته اليونار وبحسب
ايمان نشر في الصحف الاسبانيه فانما ملفات
دراسه الاميره البالغه من العمر 17 عاما
مغطى بصوره اللاعب الاسباني وانه من
المسابقه ان تشهد العلاقه بين الاثنين
تطورا كبيرا بعد نهايته مونديال قطر
ونبقى مع اخبار المونديال لحيته طالع تي
في المدير الفني للمنتخب البرازيلي تقديم
اعتذاره قبل مباراه منتخب بلاده امام
كوريا الجنوبيه بسبب الاسطوره والاعدم
ثمانيه سته الشفاء اسطوره القدم
البرازيليه الذي يعاني حاليا من مرض
السرطان بدايه المؤتمر الصحفي للمباراه
الماضيه المرتقبه الى جانب اجابته على احد
اسئله الصحفيين الحاضرين تيتي تدارك الامر
وقدم اعتذاره وتحدث بعدها عن علاقته ببله
ومقابلته له عام 2000 2018
وانا اختم مع صور كرودشام زوجه المدير
الفني للمنتخب الفرنسي حيث تواجدت اليوم
وفي وقت مبكر بمدرجات ملعب ثماني مسانده
زوجها ومنتخب الديوك امام بولندا في ثمن
نهائي كاس العالم 2022 والذي انتهى بفوز
المنتخب الفرنسي بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف
واحد وحجزه لبطاقه ربع نهائي مونديال 2002
[موسيقى]